[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur ladies
welt heute zeige ich euch mit meiner
bezaubernden praktikantin summiere
sag mal hallo wie ihr ganz einfach
reiniger für zu hause machen könnt ihr
braucht in eurem schrank nämlich
wirklich keine große menge an reinigern
es reicht wenn ihr zu hause immer natron
habt etwas zitronensäure habt und dann
noch ein paar ätherische öle die rede
die ich jetzt heute mache sind auch
wirklich super ich mache alles weg
reiniger einen fußboden reiniger und
einen wc bzw abflussreiniger und da
spart ihr euch zum einen viel geld viel
platz im vorratsschrank und einfach auch
ganz viel chemie auf die er wirklich
verzichten könnt jetzt machen wir mal
zuerst in allzweckreiniger zitronensäure
und natron gibt es übrigens entweder im
supermarkt in der drogerie oder können
auch online bestellen ganz günstig
wirklich so fünf kilo packs hab s
einfach auf vorrat und dann könnt ihr
jederzeit eure reiniger machen also
jetzt machen wir zuerst mal den
allzweckreiniger der allzweckreiniger
kommt dann in der sprühflasche und damit
könnt ihr dann alle gängigen oberflächen
reinigen also im badezimmer die küchen
oberflächen was haben wir noch die
schränke alles was wir so abstauben und
abwischen wollen machen wir mit diesem
allzweckreiniger dafür braucht ihr 500
gramm wasser 2 ist soviel spülmittel 20
gramm essigessenz zehn tropfen teebaumöl
und fünf tropfen zitronenöl noch kurz
der den einzelnen bestandteilen das
wasser brauche ich natürlich zum
verdünnen
damit das ganze sprüh fähig wird
spülmittel ist so konzipiert dass auch
wenn mal kinder zum beispiel abspülen
und man hat spülmittel reste auf
geschirr und besteck dass es einfach
nicht schädlich ist also ist es wirklich
kinderfreundlich essig ist total
geruchsneutralisierende es ist reinigen
und desinfizieren
außerdem ist er kalk lösen teebaumöl ist
auch total desinfizierend und bringt
einfach nochmal an schönen duft mit rein
und hier habe ich noch zitronenöl das
bringt jetzt hier die frische mit rein
und da nehme ich einfach mein back öl
also diesen bug aroma von deco bak habe
ich immer in der backshop lade und das
könnt ihr nehmen weil es einfach zu 100%
zitronenöl ist das ist alles also mehr
brauchen wir nicht
okay sie miramax das zusammenmischen uns
nimmst dich einfach spülmittel
zwei esslöffel hockey perfekt jetzt esse
ich es ist übrigens auch total fed lösen
und der neutralisiert würde ich wirklich
alle gerüchte ich gebe auch immer so ein
spritzer essig mit in die spülmaschine
hier rein und dann brauche ich gerade
noch ein bisschen mehr dann bisschen
jetzt 15 gramm jetzt so ein bisschen
noch passt perfekt local auswaschen
jetzt machst du teebaumöl oder
zitronenöl okay bei diesen zehn tropfen
sicherheitsrats
[Musik]
wenn ihr jetzt den teebaumöl duft nicht
so sehr mit
dann nehmt einfach nur ein bisschen mehr
zitronenöl ihr könnt orangenöl zum
beispiel nehmen ich will nämlich nach
dem putzen das ist einfach immer schön
frisch riecht und das sind für mich
einfach zitrusfrüchte und ist gut
richtig gut
jetzt kommt es hier einfach in so eine
sprühflasche und das war es dann schon
vor der benutzung einfach immer gut
durchschütteln
denn die öle stimmen jetzt oben und
damit könnt ihr jetzt wirklich schön
alles einigen
[Musik]
das reicht schon
damit könnte jetzt oberflächen reinigen
fensterrahmen reinigen
tische und möbel abstauben kindermöbel
reinigen und noch vieles mehr sehr gut
dann können wir schon den zweiten
reiniger zubereiten ja jetzt stellen wir
einen wc reiniger abflussreiniger und
stadtreiniger her
dafür braucht ihr nur drei zutaten wir
haben hier zum einen natron
zitronensäure und orangenöl für den duft
natron verwenden wir weil natron schmutz
und flecken lösen ist davon ist auch
wirklich ein ganz natürliches produkt
wird auch schon immer als heil produkt
und als wundermittel eingesetzt war kann
es zum beispiel auch auf matratzen
darauf streuen auf teppiche einwirken
lassen und absaugen also nato nimmt auch
wirklich wunderbar flecken flecken und
gerüche auf und zitronen sollte die
wurde ursprünglich sogar aus zitronen
extrahiert mittlerweile kann man es aber
auch bier technisch herstellen
zitronensäure löst kalkflecken und
schont dabei eben auch armaturen und vor
allem dichtungen also ich habe auch oft
immer gerne mit essigessenz geputzt aber
es greift kunststoff und dichtungen an
und zitronensäure ist einfach schön und
zitronensäure nehme ich zum beispiel
auch gerne wenn t kann einmal verkalkt
sind oder kaffeemaschinen
dann nehmt ihr einfach pure
zitronensäure könnte ich auch den
entkalker sparen denn alles was so ein
entkalker hat ist wirklich nur pure
zitronensäure also könnte da auch
wirklich viel geld sparen
und hier habe ich dann noch das orange
weil ich hier jetzt einfach möchte dass
alles lecker nach orange riecht und
diese zwei produkte zusammen machen
übrigens auch eure fugen im badezimmer
supersauber also das kann man wirklich
auch wieder individuell und überall
einsetzen
das wird einfach beides vermischt
möchtest du genauen handschuhe anziehen
gehen wir noch das orangenöl dazu man
kann daraus theoretisch auch wz ups
machen und da jetzt ein bisschen wasser
drüber sprühen und dann so ein bisschen
bei nebel
hier darf jetzt einfach nicht viel
wasser rein sonst reagiert sie schon
miteinander genau kurz vermischen damit
sich das öl verteilt so ein bisschen
durchkneten
[Musik]
mit setups spar ich mir weil so kann ich
einfach immer dosieren ob ich etwas
weniger war oder etwas mehr braucht auch
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr gerne auch
die topstars machen aber das ist er
nicht nur fürs wc ist sondern eben auch
für einen abfluss und für fugen mache
ich das jetzt hier ins glas könnte auch
gleich eine riesenmenge herstellen
[Musik]
wenn ihr damit jetzt euer wc reinigen
möchte dann gebt ihr einfach heißes
kochendes wasser in das wc rhein lebt
dann etwa zwei esslöffel von der
mischung darüber dann sprudelte so ein
bisschen ihr könnt uns schön mit einer
klobürste noch darüber reiben wenn ihr
den abschluss reinigen wollt dann gebt
ihr davon auch etwas in den abfluss
hinein gibt ganz wenig wasser nur
darüber dass wirklich wie so eine art
passte im abfluss entsteht das blutbad
auch wirklich eine ganze zeit lang löst
alle verschmutzungen löst haare und
lässt den abschluss wieder frei werden
und wenn ihr damit die fugen sauber
machen wollt im wartezimmer
dann nehmt ihr einfach nur ganz wenig
wasser macht wie so eine art passte
streicht über die fugen drüber last kurz
einwirken und spielst dann wieder sauber
super und ganz natürlich hergestellt ok
kommen wir zum dritten reiniger und das
wird jetzt der boden reiniger beim boden
reiniger kommt jetzt natürlich auch
darauf an was für einen boden ihr habt
also wir haben bei uns im haus parkett
also einen holzboden ganz natürlichen
wir haben sich beton estrich wir haben
fließen und wir haben zehn platten also
diese via platten und bei all unseren
böden kann ich jetzt einen reiniger
herstellen mit schmierseife schmierseife
wird nämlich entfernt also schon löst
auch schmutz aber weckt auch rückfettend
und so ein liter schmierseife kostet
ungelogen 95 cent
ihr könnt euch wirklich damit eindecken
und das ist total ergiebig ich brauche
nämlich wirklich nur ein bis zwei
esslöffeln je nachdem wie schmutzig der
boden ist zu viel darf man nicht nehmen
weil es dann wirklich auch schmier
flecken hinterlässt und ansonsten
brauche ich jetzt nur wasser nehmen dann
die schmierseife und für den duft
orangenöl oder zitronenöl und beim einen
holzboden also beim parkett nämlich noch
etwas leinöl dazu damit einfach der
boden noch mal so schön so ein bisschen
versiegelt wird und mit öl rück gefettet
wird das war es schon
also damit könnt ihr auch wirklich alle
böden reinigen und wenn ihr da noch
fragen habt schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare
ich würde bei allem reinigern egal was
jetzt macht und bei allen oberflächen
immer empfehlen probiert trotzdem erst
mal an einer unsichtbaren stelle aus an
der stelle die man nicht so unbedingt
gleich sieht man weiß ja nie aber die
reiniger wirklich benutze ich für alle
oberflächen probiert gerne mal aus und
ansonsten wünschen wir euch viel spaß
beim putzen
ich lade dringend jetzt nach und nach
meine putts videos hoch ich habe nämlich
frühjahrsputz
macht und habe mit gefilmt wie ihr
wirklich ganz effizient zeit sparen
schnell und mit viel spaß ihr haus oder
ihre wohnung putzen könnt und vielleicht
noch eins dazu wir haben jetzt die
reiniger hergestellt größtenteils aus
natürlichen produkten aber ihr solltet
die reiniger trotzdem immer so
aufbewahren dass kinder nichts dran
kommen also auch bei schwer seife auch
bei natron und zitronensäure immer im
außer reichweite von kindern aufbewahrt
und dann habt ihr ein schönes sauberes
haus und bis zum nächsten mal vielleicht
habt ihr auch reinigungs tipps die ihr
mit uns teilen wollt dann schreibt sie
gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]